The most important thing to know
when selling is knowing who you're
selling to and what they care about.
So understanding who is standing in
front of you, whether it's an investor,
an employee, or customer, or partner,
and what they truly care about
really dictates the tone of what
you're selling and how you sell it.
For that you need to be
able to know everything and
anything about your business.
So you can tune your pitch to
whoever is standing across from you.
So if in a networking event,
it's an investor and
you pick it up very quickly you
can have a very specific pitch
that is different then if across
from you is a potential new hire.
So knowing who that person is is
probably the most important and
first step of developing
your pitching skills and
then obviously the thing that will get
you good at it is just again practicing.
The more you practice the better you'll
be good at it and you can probably
measure it because your pitches
will become significantly shorter.
It's really easy to sell something
using lots of sentences and
many minutes.
It's really hard to do so
with a few words and a few seconds and
the more you practice the better
you'll become at selling.